it blows my mind every time I do those
things where people are like oh you're
nice and you really like your fans I'm
like yes what's the what's the
alternative they're like Oh everybody
else then it's just so crazy to me it's
crazy to me please so many of you and so
many of you that's not true a couple of
you are going to break out follow this
blueprint win become something have
people admire you and care about you
want to take a selfie want to get the
book signed please please don't become
that person that ever takes it for
granted remember where you came from
remember where you came from it really
matters never never ever lose that
gratitude of another even even if you
have four people following you right now
never you know never lose the gratitude
for those four and I think it's very
easy and so that's that's kind of the
memorable moment Barack how many people
want to be aligned when after watching
me talk for an hour or answer questions
wanted to stay in line for an hour and a
half to get a selfie are you kidding me
that uh that's the greatest high in the
world
you